We all need the ability to communicate private information without fear of anyone eavesdropping. But designing a
foolproof system for this isn't easy. In today's episode of Qiskit in the Classroom, we'll talk about how
something called quantum key distribution can
help. Welcome back to Qiskit in the Classroom. In the series, we'll cover topics you might encounter in a quantum
computing related university course. Each video comes with an interactive module linked in the description, so
make sure you check that out. Today, we'll venture into the realm of quantum cryptography. Cryptography is the study
of techniques for secure communication. This is incredibly important to many parts of our lives. Every time you use a
password to log into a website, send a digital payment, or when governments transmit military intel, it's all done
through some cryptographic protocol so that an easedropper can't learn our secrets. But there's a tension here. How
do we ensure that the person we want to communicate with can understand our message, but nobody else can?
Historically, cryptographers have come up with a lot of different protocols to try to make their messages as immune
from eavesdroppers as possible. Sometimes the two parties that want to securely communicate agree upon some
code beforehand that hopefully is so complicated that an eavesdropper wouldn't be able to crack it. But as
people like Alan Touring and other wartime code breakers have shown us, even the most complicated codes can be
cracked. Ideally, we'd like to send messages that are encrypted in such a way that there's absolutely no pattern
and no way that an easedropper can understand without also having a secret random key that only the sender and the
receiver know. But then we open ourselves up to a new vulnerability. How can we send this key and be sure that
nobody intercepts it? In 1984, Charles Bennett and Jill Brousard came up with a
method to securely send a key with quantum bits, which is now called BB84. The key feature of these quantum
bits or cubits that enables this protocol is that they obey the uncertainty principle. You can't measure
a quantum system without disturbing it. Today, we'll start with an example of a simple cryptographic code. Then I'll
show you how quantum key distribution and the uncertainty principle can enable us to use nearly uncrackable
encryptions. I'll walk you through the BB84 protocol in detail and finally we'll run it on a real quantum
computer. First, let's start with a game you might have seen before called a cryptogram.
You're given a sequence of seemingly random letters, but by using your knowledge of patterns in the English
language, you can substitute one letter for another to make sense of the message. Here's an example. This is a
secret message with a simple substitution cipher. So, all the Rs represent one letter, M's represent
another, and so on. If you want to try your hand at solving this yourself, pause the video now.
It turns out that this message was encrypted using a very simple cipher called the Caesar cipher where the
alphabet is just shifted by a certain number in this case 9. So A becomes J, B
becomes K, C becomes L and so on. The longer the message, the easier it is to
see the pattern. So, with a message as long as the one we're given, the Caesar cipher or any other cipher that just
substitutes one letter in the alphabet for another is pretty simple to crack. A more secure way to encode a secret
message is with a so-called one-time pad. With a one-time pad, you can have a different shift for each letter in the
message. You just need to tell your friend what the shift was on each one so they can decode the message.
This list of shifts is called the key or the pad. It's called the one-time pad because it's used once then discarded.
If it's used more than that, patterns will emerge which could make the encryption crackable. With the one-time
pad encryption, both the encrypted message and the key individually are just a random string of nonsense. But
when you put them together, you see a secret message emerge from the noise.
Let's do a short example. Say I have already created and sent my friend this one time pad which is usually written in
binary. And then I want to send the message I love quantum. Then I would encode the message
using the one-time pad like this. First we convert the letters in our message to binary. Each letter A through Z will
correspond to the numbers 1 through 26 written in binary. So A will be 0 0
0 1 B 0 0 1
0 C 0 0 1 1 and so
on. And then a space will be just all zeros.
Then this is what the message becomes. We encode the message by performing an exor between each bit in the message and
its corresponding bit in the one-time pad. If you haven't seen exor before, it
stands for exclusive or. The exor between two bits will be one if only one
of the bits is one and zero if they're either both zero or both one. So the first set of five bits in the encoded
message becomes 1 0
0 1 1. I'll leave the rest of the exors for you to do on your own. But the point is
this message is now just a random string of zeros and ones with no pattern. It's completely indecipherable by anyone who
doesn't have the one-time pad that we use to encrypt the message. So, what have we learned so far? Some encryption
schemes are better than others, and some can be inferred by a smart person looking for patterns in the encrypted
message. But a truly random key that shifts each letter in a secret message a different random amount cannot be
inferred because there are no patterns in the message. The only vulnerability in a scheme like this is making sure
that the key that was used to encrypt the message does not fall into the wrong hands. Here's where quantum key
distribution comes in. By using cubits, Bennett and Brousard came up with a way for two parties to agree upon a key and
be reasonably sure that a third party wasn't secretly listening. This BB84 protocol is a little complicated, but
we'll walk through it step by step. For this explanation, let's bring back our old friends, Alice and